Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Island im Achtelfinale, wenn die sich nitzpolitisch nochmal genauso durchsetzen würden in Europa, das wäre doch mal was, oder?
Ja wir könnten tatsächlich mal so eine Netzpolitik EM äh ausrufen. Vielleicht auch mit zu diesem ähnlichen Elan, den die Menschen jetzt für dieses Thema aufbringen und die Begeisterung, die da förmlich sprudelt.
Genau, mehr Gesänge.
Lokbuch Netzpolitik Nummer einhundertsechsundachtzig wieder zum Wochenende euer Stückchen geschilderter Depression.
Heute wird's wieder, heute gibt's wieder eine ordentliche Ladung, Depression.
Ja, paar Ohrfeigen wieder fürs Gemüt. Stimmt, oder?
Ja, aber ich fühle mich also ja, mir ist einfach mal wieder aufgefallen, wie äh dass wir ja äh durchaus eine äh gepflegte Diskussions und Kommentarkultur auf Lokbuchnetzpolitik DE haben.
Äh viel mir gerade bei den äh kontroverseren Themen, die wir in der letzten Woche behandelt haben,
jetzt mal wieder in der Kommentarspalte auf. Kann man einen kann man zu einladen.
Ja, sollten wir es auch generell so ein Phänomen, dass das bei Podcasts sich ganz anders entwickelt als so bei Blogs üblicherweise,
deutlich weniger Geschrei ähm
die sagen frei von kontroverse aber man hat schon so den Eindruck, wenn Leute sich äh längere Zeit mal ausführlich gesprochenem Wort äh ausliefern und dann anfangen äh zu denken und Schlüsse zu ziehen, dass es doch sehr viel besser ist, als wenn man
nur auf Headlines reagiert
insofern vielleicht auch ganz praktisch, dass unsere Headlines eigentlich immer mit dem Inhalt nichts zu tun haben. Vielleicht wäre das auch mal eine Strategie für Blogs
Wobei, na ja, mit den ganzen Listicals und so weiter geht das ja eigentlich auch schon in die Richtung.
Da gab's doch auch mal so so Forschungen, wo sie einfach irgendwie, also ich erinnere mich da dunkel, dass es da mal irgendwie so eine Studie gab, die einfach irgendwas in den Titel geschrieben haben und der Inhalt war halt von was ganz anderem,
handelte.
Und die Kommentare zu großen Teilen, also dann haben sie natürlich so Reizthemen genommen und waren halt Kommentare zu dem Thema, was nur im Titel irgendwie stand und der Artikel selber hatte von was ganz anderem gehandelt
und äh jede Person, die den Artikel gelesen hätte,
hätte eben zu einem anderen Thema äh kommentiert. Ich glaube, da stand dann sogar in dem Artikel drin, so irgendwie das erste so, das, was der Text, der nun folgen wird, hat mit dem Titel überhaupt nichts zu tun. Äh es handelt sich hier um ein kleines Experiment,
oder soll das, was der erste Satz und die Leute aber nicht mal den ersten Satz gelesen sofor.
Ja.
Ich ich muss das, ich muss.
Ja, wir sollten vielleicht auch so auf List Tickets gehen und so, so. Fünf, fünf Länder, die netzpolitischer Europameister werden können,
Mal gucken.
Klickschrecke.
Man muss ja um, ja, Klickstrecke, man muss ja auch ein bisschen hier, weißt du? Jetzt ist Sommer, dreiunddreißig Grad, Sonnenschein, die Leute äh sitzen schon so ein bisschen ausgedünstet auf der Bank und jetzt oh, jetzt Podcast hören und so, dann fußballgeil.
Ja, früher ist offenbar geil. Wir müssen, wir brauchen offenbar mehr. Mehr Board hängen.
Genau, du Freunde. Ja, mehr Boateng haben wir leider nicht wirklich im Angebot. Was haben wir denn im Angebot?
Doch schon einige Fallrückzieher möchte ich sagen.
Ja, super, jetzt.
Ich kann das auch.
Ja, ja, wir wollen ja hier nicht abseits stehen.
In Deutschland möchte man sich ähm mit äh muss man dem Terror im Internet natürlich äh ein Ende bereiten, ähm wie wir wissen, kommt der Terror ja aus dem Internet zu uns und manifestiert sich dann in der.
In der Realität.
Für die böse Glasfaser. Deswegen darf man die auch nicht überall verlegen.
Nee.
Also es gibt das wurde bei Netzpolitik nochmal schön zusammengefasst, es gibt das,
Internetforum, die sich irgendwie äh damit auseinandersetzen, wie man den Zugang zu terroristischen Inhalten einschränken kann. Es gibt von Europol die Meldestelle für Internet in Anhalt, Inhalte,
wo ähm Löschlöschanträge eben entgegengenommen werden,
Und in Deutschland gibt's ja auch letztes Jahr seit letztem Jahr schon diese Taskforce, die sich irgendwie mit rechtswidrigen,
Hassbotschaften im Internet auseinandersetzt, dann gibt's ja noch so freiwillige Selbstverpflichtungen für generelle,
Hate Speed, der dann irgendwie auf Facebook steht, wo dann irgendwie feierlich verkündet wurde. Wir löschen das jetzt innerhalb vierundzwanzig Stunden, also wenn es in der Timeline irgendwo so am anderen Ende des Planeten angekommen ist.
Also unten und jetzt hat man sich überlegt, wir brauchen ja auch noch einen Antiterror-Paket ähm und da gesellen sich,
nun äh Maßnahmen gegen terroristische Propaganda,
hinzu. Da gibt's also einen Gesetzesentwurf, der sollte jetzt auch erst im Bundeskabinett beschlossen werden, dann ist es aber doch nicht passiert oder so. Und da gibt's aber jetzt einen spannenden Punkt, denn,
Die Betreiber von Online-Plattformen sollen gemäß dieses Gesetzentwurfes in Zukunft selbständig und aktiv gegen terroristische Propaganda vorgehen.
Geile Idee.
Dieser Maßnahmenkatalog wurde schon irgendwie Mitte April veröffentlicht,
und da stand also schon drin. Wir wollen eine freiwillige Selbstverpflichtung der Unternehmen, der Internetwirtschaft zum Selbstständigen und aktiven Vorgehen gegen terroristische Propaganda auf ihren Netzwerken,
Flankiert werden soll das Ganze. Wir werden zudem die Möglichkeit einer europarechtlichen Verschärfung des Host Provider Privilegs,
das heißt die Haftung der Horst Provider für Inhalte prüfen.
So. Warum wollen die das machen? Also sie, es ist natürlich sehr, so eine freiwillige Selbstverpflichtung ist natürlich insofern aus Sicht des Staates angenehmer, weil sie dann nicht,
klare Regeln definieren müssen. Du sagst einfach, sagt halt der Hostingprovider ja, wir verpflichten uns freiwillig selbst,
irgendwie so Terror, Terrorpropaganda zu entfernen.
Diese Terrorpropaganda kann natürlich auch in Sprachen stattfinden, die wir nicht verstehen oder so und dann gehen wir,
aktiv und selbstständig dagegen vor?
Und der zweite Vorteil ist, also du brauchst das nicht klar zu definieren oder zweite Vorteil aus Sicht des Staates ist überhaupt kein Richtervorbehalt, ne? Weil freiwillige Selbstverpflichtungen der Wirtschaft, die dann einfach,
selbstständig und aktiv,
Sachen löscht. Das Ganze noch zu flankieren mit einer Erhöhung oder einer Verschärfung der Haftung heißt im Klartext, im Moment hast du die Situation,
Ich habe das auch glaube ich schon mal öfter als Beispiel eines jetzt, also der sinngemäß eines Kommentares bei Logbuch Netzpolitik irgendjemand äh
würde jetzt was ja bei uns nicht vorkommt eine eine Hassbotschaft als Kommentar unter unsere Seite schreiben und dann würde sie dort veröffentlich ja? Und nun,
In diesem Moment haften wir erstmal nicht dafür. Wenn wir aber darüber in Kenntnis gesetzt werden, hier wir.
Weisen euch darauf hin. Hier ist eine Hassbotschaft, hier wird zum Mord an einer Person aufgerufen oder was auch immer,
In dem Moment haften wir dafür,
Oder du stehst gleich im Impressum. Und dann musst du dann muss in diesem ab diesem Moment musst du das löschen, weil du davon Kenntnisse erlangt hast. Und das ist eine ähm,
ziemlich gute Regelung, bin könnte man im Prinzip Notes and Takedown nennen, weil es heißt, dass ähm rechtswidrigere Inhalte.
Eben entfernt werden, aber dass es dass wir nicht aktiv ähm dagegen vorgehen müssen,
ähm ohne darüber in Kenntnis zu sein oder ohne äh rechtliche Prüfung.
Weil sonst müsste man ja auf fünfundzwanzig Stunden am Tag äh wach sein, immer alles im Blick haben, nichts übersehen dürfen, nichts falsch interpretieren, als das sozusagen gedacht ist. Und selbst dann kann er mir sogar noch vorgeworfen worden, wenn er hätte irgendwas übersehen, weil man's nicht, weiß ich nicht
verstanden übersehen hat, keine Ahnung, was auch immer. Geht auch einfach gar nicht.
Und dieses äh also das.
Es ist eben ein Grundrechtseingriff in die Meinungsfreiheit, wenn du sowas löscht, ja. Und äh im Moment geht das eben nur auf gesetzlicher äh Grundlage,
dass du, dass du so etwas tust. Wenn das jetzt umgekehrt wird und gesagt wird, pass auf, was auch immer bei dir äh veröffentlicht wird, dafür haftest du, also sieh mal zu, dass du da aufpasst, dann hätte das für uns zur Folge, dass wir sagen würden, uh ähm,
Lass uns mal lieber.
Vorsichtig sein, bevor wir irgendwie einen auf den Deckel kriegen. Und wenn wir dann eben freiwillig selbst verpflichtet wären, würden wir im Zweifelsfall eher Dinge löschen.
Weil wir wissen, dass wir da haften. Und äh diese ähm.
Vorauserheilender Gehorsam.
Dieser vorauseilende Gehorsam, der eben ein über ähm Blocking zufolge hätte,
der soll da jetzt quasi sehr stark begünstigt werden. Da gibt's Kritik von allen Enden. Bernhard Roleder, der Geschäftsführer des Bitcom, also dem,
Branchenverband der IT und Kommunikationsunternehmen in Deutschland, der sagte also auch, also wenn der Staat die Entscheidung aus der Hand gibt, was jetzt illegal ist,
Dann ist doch klar, dass damit eine vorschnelle Löschung äh erreicht wird und damit das Gegenteil dessen, was man eigentlich möchte,
Und er sagt also die Feststellung einer Rechtswidrigkeit ist nach unserer Überzeugung eine staatliche Hoheitsaufgabe welche von der Privatwirtschaft weder geleistet werden kann noch geleistet werden sollte.
Volker Trip, der ja auch kürzlich bei uns zu Gast war von der digitalen Gesellschaft sagt, na ja, das läuft eben auf eine Privatisierung staatliche Aufgaben zu Lasten der Grundrechte hinaus und schadet außerdem der europäischen Onlinewirtschaft, denn das muss ja auch noch alles gemacht werden. Die müssten dafür ja
Leute bereitstellen, die dann eben aktiv die ganze Zeit Sachen,
prüfen und vorsichtshalber mal rausnehmen. Das ist also eine ziemlich,
schlechte Idee, dann sollte dieses anti äh Terrorpaket im Innenausschuss ähm debattiert werden.
Die Koalition hat dann eben eingeladen die Chefs von Bundespolizei, Verfassungsschutz und BKA,
Die mit diesem neuen Gesetz äh alle natürlich äh erweiterte und neue, schöne Befugnisse bekommen. Da geht's ja noch um äh äh weitere äh Maßnahmen, die wir jetzt hierbei ähm derzeit geschuldet erstmal nicht betrachten.
Das ist super, ja? Also alle Experten, die man überhaupt, deren man nur habhaft hat werden können, die hat die anderen hatten wir keinen, hatten wir keine Adressen irgendwann hier.
Es ist so der Klassiker irgendwie, wie du sagst, ah, wir wollen hier was regulieren, dann laden wir mal die ein, die wir regulieren wollen, dann sagen die uns, ob das in Ordnung ist oder nicht, wie wir sie regulieren wollen, ne? Da ist halt irgendwie so, na ja ähm,
Das hat dann eben dazu geführt, dass einige der oder es die Oppositionsleute irgendwie unter Protest den Sitzungssaal verlassen haben. Also da geht's gerade ähm heiß her,
Andrea Vosshof äh bewertete den Gesetzesentwurf ähm.
Auf die Datenschutzbeauft.
Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte gesetzt von der Bundesregierung, ihr CDU-Parteibuch ähm.
Die immerhin alle drei Monate maßgeblich dazu beiträgt, dass man sich daran erinnert, dass sie noch nicht gestorben ist.
Genau, die sagt dann, selbst die sagt, also der Gesetzesentwurf setzt, setzt die verfassungsgerichtlichen Vorgaben nicht hinreichend um, sodass erhebliche verfassungsrechtliche Bedenken bestehen.
Ähm der Hamburger Datenschutzbeauftragte Johannes Kasper hat gesagt, äh die Begriffe sind hier schwammig und damit eben auch die Kompetenzdefinition dehnbar und äh,
Natürlich als Datenschutzbeauftragter äh wehrt er sich gegen die Schaffung einer internationalen Verbunddatei, denn natürlich soll hier der internationale Datenaustaustausch zwischen Geheimdiensten,
erleichtert werden in diesem Antiterrorpaket, weil wir damit ja, wie wir im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss regelmäßig hören. So tolle äh Erfahrungen hatten.
Dann ähm wurde kurz vor der finalen Abstimmung jetzt nochmal einen Änderungseintrag von Abgeordneten der Union und SPD eingebracht, wo sie sagten, ajo, was wir auch noch machen könnten ist, wir könnten das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz ähm,
er bemächtigen.
Nicht nur Personen ab sechzehn Jahren zu überwachen, sondern Personen ab vierzehn Jahren, weil von denen ja die größte terroristische Gefahr eindeutig in Deutschland ausgeht,
und außerdem könnten wir ja dann die,
Auf ähm Hebung der SIM-Anonymität, wo wir ja auch schon drüber gesprochen haben, alles Maßnahmen, die da reingehören, ähm mal noch schneller machen und nicht erst in achtzehn, sondern schon in zwölf Monaten.
Absetzen. Äh äh von A von achtzehn Monaten auf zwölf Monate herabsetzen. Ähm.
Für diese Verschärfung hatte sich der Verfassungsschutzpräsident Maaßen bei der Sachverständigenanhörung, die am Montag stattfand,
schon bei Union und SPD bedankt. Da war die aber noch gar nicht öffentlich. Das heißt ja,
Hat mal wieder Landesverrat begangen und ähm quasi,
Entscheidung, die noch nicht äh eingebracht waren und noch nicht öft oder ja Abgeordnetenanträge, die noch nicht öffentlich waren, äh da schon quasi,
Teil öffentlich gemacht oder seine Kenntnis über diese Anträge verraten.
Indem er sich da dann nochmal im öffentlichen, in der öffentlichen Anhörung,
dafür bedankt hat. Die finale Abstimmung über das Gesetz wurde jetzt auf den Freitag, vierundzwanzigsten Juni verschoben. Heute ist der Donnerstag dreiundzwanzigster Juni.
Fühle mich gleich viel sicherer, Linus. Also wenn ich jetzt weiß, dass auch irgendwie die Vierzehnjährigen äh endlich ja.
Also das ist ein eine eine Reihe an Maßnahmen. Ich kann mir da schon ungefähr vorstellen gegen wie viele oder auch gegen welche Suppe,
Wir denn da eben in naher Zukunft dann wieder.
Verfassungsgerichtsbeschwerde haben.
Gerichtsbeschwerden haben und entsprechend auf entsprechende Urteile warten und.
Ein Jahr später wird das dann alles wieder zurückgenommen und dann auch sorry und jetzt ist es schön, dass wir die Klarstellung haben.
Schön, dass wir genau auf das wir jetzt definiert haben, wo die rote Linie.
Fühlen uns ja grundsätzlich genau, wir fühlen uns ja grundsätzlich auch bestätigt und das bestärkt ja auch äh nicht wahr, die Linie der Bundesregierung. Schnarch.
Glücklicherweise wird das Ganze ja flankiert durch eine Terrorismusrichtlinie der EU, ja? Das heißt, wenn wir dann,
quasi dieses Antiterror-Paket in Teilen wieder weggeklagt haben, dann kam man die gleiche Debatte wie bei der Vorratsseitenspeicherung, nämlich dass das ja, dass er hier eine EU-Richtlinie
umgesetzt werden muss, handelt die umgesetzt werden muss, denn EU-Richtlinien müssen ja von der Regierung der Mitgliedsstaaten anschließend in
nationales Recht umgesetzt werden,
und da auf der EU-Ebene sagte man sich dann eben nach den Anschlägen von Paris, sagte man, oh jetzt müssen wir aber schnell,
Ein paar an die Terrormaßnahmen umsetzen, die wir in der Schublade haben,
Und zwar sparen wir uns doch am besten mal das übliche Impact Assessment und beginnen direkt mit dem Gesetzgebungsprozess.
Und da gab es dann ein,
ging man dann los und knappe drei Monate später gab es dann eine nicht formelle Einschätzung des Rats, wo noch so ein paar Ideen dazu kam,
Man könnte nämlich zum Beispiel Websperren ähm mit da aufnehmen äh bei.
Die für Seiten.
Die für Seiten die öffentlich zur Begehung terroristischer Straftaten auffordern?
Und man könnte ja ähm.
Die Erfassung, Registrierung und Aufnahme von Äußerung und Gesprächen in privaten oder öffentlichen Fahrzeugen oder an privaten oder öffentlichen Orten.
Sophie, sowie das Anfertigen von Bildmaterial von Personen in öffentlichen Fahrzeugen und an öffentlichen äh Orten erleichtern.
Also da auch die Kompetenzen ausweiten. Das Ganze,
Ist für das Ganze ist federführend der Ausschuss äh für bürgerliche Freiheiten, Justiz und Inneres, der Liebeausschuss.
Wo dann ebenfalls Vorschläge und Ergänzung äh angebracht wurden. Äh insgesamt glaube ich äh,
wurden in diesen Ausschuss vierhundertachtunddreißig Änderungsvorschläge äh eingebracht. Und was jetzt hier interessant ist, üblicherweise hast du einen leitenden Ausschuss und mehrere andere, die ihre Einschätzung an diesen,
Ausschuss reporten.
Das ist jetzt nicht so.
Das ist jetzt nicht so, hier ist ausschließlich der Liebeausschuss beschäftigt und der tut das unter äh der,
Berichterstatterin Monika Hohlmeier von der CSU.
Oh Gott. Auch bekannt als die Tochter von Französisch Strauß.
Ja. Nomen ist oben und der Apfel äh fällt nicht weit vom Stamm,
Und diese vierhundertachtunddreißig äh Änderungsvorschläge werden also jetzt in einer Kleingruppe von nur acht Ausschussmitgliedern.
Zusammen kondensiert. Das Ganze findet dann eben hinter verschlossenen Türen statt. Und dann wird für die kontroversen Punkte ein Kompromiss äh Vorschlag äh.
Irgendwann dort stehen. Mit diesem Kompromissvorschlag geht dann Monika Hohlmeier von der CSU direkt in den ähm Trilog,
und da kann sie äh machen, was sie möchte. In Bezug auf die äh,
Netzsperren. Ach so, also wenn dann diese Trilogverhandlungen abgeschlossen sind äh werden die Mitgliedsstaaten eben das Ergebnis in äh Rat und Parlament ähm,
zur Kenntnis nehmen.
Hast du, vielleicht bist du da jetzt überfragt, aber was mich jetzt gerade wundert, ist auf Basis welcher Regelung und Entscheidungen oder Gesetzeslage an dieser Stelle äh das Statement des Parlaments, denn übergangen werden kann,
ein ein Parlamentsausschuss äh,
den Bericht vorliegt durch die Berichterstatterin diesem Fall, dann ist das ja zunächst einmal eine Entscheidungsgrundlage für das Parlament. Dessen.
Abstimmung ist dann das, was der Kommission vorgelegt wird und in der Folge äh dazu kommt es ja dann zum,
Triolog, also dem eigentlichen Oskaspern von, was machen wir denn jetzt wirklich? Woher dann meistens auf den letzten Metern dann irgendwie wirklich die wünschenswerten Details äh fallen, wie bei der Netzneutralität? Also ist das jetzt hier irgendwo also auf welcher Basis ist das jetzt hier anders.
Also da gibt's ein ein.
Einen längeren Artikel von Joe McNeme und der sagte, also wenn die Trilogverhandlungen abgeschlossen sind, dann haben ja quasi alle drei an einem Tisch gesessen und dann kommt ja die Berichterstatterin mit ihrem,
Gesetzestext zurück ins Parlament,
Und dann so schreibt äh John McNeme hier. Wenn das einmal passiert ist, sobald die Trilogverhandlungen abgeschlossen sind, werden die Mitgliedsstaaten im Rat und das Parlament das Ergebnis ihrer Verhandler wohl abnicken,
weil es zu dem Zeitpunkt dann nahezu unmöglich ist, weitere Änderungen vorzunehmen.
Ja klar, dann ist es durch, aber bevor
jetzt der Weg in den Trilog geht, müsste eigentlich das Parlament nochmal zu dem Vorschlag des Ausschusses sich äußern und darüber abstimmen und da sehen wir es halt häufig, dass dass diese Aushandlungen dann eben vom Parlament abgesegnet wird, ob das jetzt in diesem Fall dann auch,
Übersprungen werden kann, ist mir jetzt ein.
Also über Sprung, wo also der Gesetzesvorschlag kommt von der Kommission.
Klar, weil die Kommission hat ja immer das Initiativrecht, dieses Parlament kann ja von sich aus gar nichts machen. Die Kommission sagt, wir müssen da mal was machen. Liebes Parlament nimmt auch mal Statement dazu, dann kommt halt der Ausschuss, in diesem Fall der Liebeausschuss
Berichterstatter oder Berichterstatterin, die legen dann ihr Ergebnis vor, was das Parlament meinen sollte, geben das Parlament, das Parlament hat dann darüber abzustimmen,
Diese Abstimmung ist dann sozusagen das, was definiert, was der Kommission vorgelegt wird und womit es dann sozusagen in den Tridog äh geht. Also ich.
Ja, aber das ist doch das ist ja das, was äh Monika Hohlmeier jetzt macht.
Nee, klar, so wie du es nur nur wie du es jetzt beschrieben hast, äh habe ich das so rausgehört, dass du meinst äh der Ausschuss,
Handelt das aus und ohne dass das Parlament nochmal ein Statement machen muss, geht es gleich in den Trilog, das bezweifle ich,
Aber trotz alledem haben wir ja oft gesehen, den Ausschüssen wird dann halt äh gefolgt und von daher ist natürlich die Macht der Berichterstatter äh groß, das haben wir ja auch in anderen Bereichen, die wir hier beleuchtet haben, schon gesehen
zum Beispiel Datenschutzverordnung äh und andere Themen. Gut, nichtsde.
Fakt ist, Monika Hohlmeier als Berichterstatterin für den Liebeausschuss handelt,
arbeitet jetzt die Position des Europäischen Parlaments aus. In diesem Liebeausschuss und geht damit dann in den Trilog. Und weil es eben ein,
Schnellverfahren quasi hier ist, wo ja sogar das Impact Assessment einfach übersprungen wurde. Impact Assessment hat den Sinn, dass man Alternativen aufzeigt.
Gut, das war jetzt meine Frage. Also es gibt sozusagen ein Schnellverfahrensprozess, der bei den dessen war ich mir bisher noch.
Den hat man sich, ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Prozess ist. Ich kann hier nur, also Joe Mcnee ist einfach derjenige, der es äh.
Wir brauchen wir brauchen jetzt gar nicht weiter diskutieren, weil wir haben's jetzt eh schon verrant und werden in den Kommentaren dann entsprechend ne von unseren freundlichen Hörerinnen und Hörern äh äh entsprechend begradigt werden.
Weil ich diese Sache immer nicht so hundertprozentig verstehe, verkünde ich hier das Wort des gesegneten Propheten Joe Macne Me, der von Etri äh genau das niedergeschrieben hat, was ich nun hier äh.
Ne, das das Stichwort war Schnellverfahren, das äh kannte ich so bisher noch nicht, dass es das äh gibt. Vielleicht gibt's das. Ich werde dem äh nochmal nachgeben.
Ich sehe da jetzt auch bis auf das fehlende Impact Assessment keinen Unterschied. Aber ich würde gerne weitermachen.
Denn spannend ist ja für uns hier mit wieder einer ganzen Menge an Sachen, wo du dann in Deutschland nochmal diskutiert. Ähm die Rolle von
Majores ergänzt Illegal Terrorist Content on DE Internet
Und da gibt es eine Formulierung, die ursprünglich lautete Member States May, Take the Nessasery Mashal Mashes to in Show, the promet removel of
elige Content,
also Mitgliedsstaaten dürfen die notwendigen Maßnahmen äh,
einleiten, um die schnelle, um das schnelle Entfernen derartiger Inhalte zu ähm,
sicherzustellen, die öffentlich dazu aufrufen terroristische Straftaten zu begehen.
Also wenn Dollar Dollar, vierzehnjähriger Terrorist äh im Internet schreibt, ich bringe euch jetzt alle um und die Bombe zündet, dann äh hat das äh darf man das und sollte man das entfernen?
So, dann hat sie das irgendwann nochmal umgeändert,
Show, also nicht mehr, sie dürfen, sondern sie sollen. Ähm was der dieses eine Wort ist eben der Unterschied zwischen wir legalisieren Netzsperren und wir zwingen zu Netzsperren,
ne? Das äh ähm ist ein äh krasser mit dieser,
dann wiederum zurückgeändert auf may, weil sie Protest bekommen hat. Aber mit dieser Formulierung geht sie nun in den Trilog. Und da kann sie jetzt eh wiederum, da kann sich ja eh nochmal alles ändern. So ist ja der Trilog.
May und Chell und Must wäre dann sozusagen das ist so ein bisschen die drei Einigkeit an der Stelle. Also May ist, kannst du machen, Shell ist, solltest du tun, aber bist auch nicht verpflichtet dazu und machst es, muss muss auf jeden Fall geschehen.
Also Fakt ist, sie wird nun ähm mit dieser äh Position in den Trilog gehen. Dort wird längere Zeit ähm,
eben hinter verschlossenen Türen äh debattiert werden und ähm dann kommt man irgendwann zurück. Also ähnlich, wie wir das ja auch in dem Film von ähm,
Jan-Philipp Albrecht und Ralph Bendrath gesehen haben, dass man dann eben wenn es dann diese Position gibt, die der Ausschuss ausgehandelt hat, mit der der Ausschuss zurückkommt ins Parlament und wo dann das Parlament,
sich hinter diesen Ausschuss stellt in der Regel.
Äh genau das Gleiche wird hier auch passieren. Und äh ja hat jetzt Pech. Das ausgerechnet diese Person da jetzt diesen Ausschuss äh.
Bestimmt dadurch, dass sie die Berichterstatterin ist und dass dieser Ausschuss jetzt hier eben alleinig arbeitet und es sehr wenig äh Möglichkeiten der Einflussnahme mehr gibt,
zu diesem Zeitpunkt. Deswegen hat äh Edri äh.
Quasi dieses Thema als seine absolute Toppriorität für die nächste Zeit.
Und äh ich denke bei der Gelegenheit kann man auch nochmal darauf,
hinweisen, dass die immer sich über Spenden freuen und dass das sehr wenige Mitarbeiter sind,
da auf der EU-Ebene die ganze Zeit diese,
Lobby, Lobbyismus betreiben in unserem Sendung, von denen wir selten hören, weil die die ganze Zeit so stark beschäftigt sind.
Ja, da fehlt noch der passende Podcast.
Welche Mindset als.
Das als wir hier Edri zu Gast hatten oder welchen Podcast meinst du? Ich habe heute Schwierigkeiten.
Nee, ein Podcast, den sie selber machen, damit man mehr von ihnen hört.
Ach so, ja, die haben einfach keine Zeit, die die hetzen ja von einem äh von einem Treffen zum anderen und und treten die Feuer aus. Also es ist da nicht.
Wir nicht oder was?
Aber bei aller, bei allem Antiterror äh muss man ja auch die Geheimdienste reformieren, ist ja auch klar.
Genau lockt Bundesnetzpolitik berichtete. Wir hatten das ja schon.
Die Sendung mit Anna, wo du das, wo ihr das versprochen habt, ähm und zwar äh gibt es ein,
Reformpaket ne also ich habe auch schon öfter mal angemerkt, dass ja meine eigentlich erwarten würde, dass sich der Inhalt dieses Reformpaketes ergeben sollte aus den Erkenntnissen des NSA,
Untersuchungsausschusses auf,
diese Möglichkeiten hat man hier weitgehend verzichtet, weil der Abschlussreport des NSA-Untersuchungsausschusses ja noch nicht vorliegt, aber ähm.
Ja, der Abschlussbericht, der ist ja egal. Nee, man hat ja festgestellt, dass alles im Argen ist und dass äh dass er die ganze Zeit gegen Gesetze verstoßen wurde, muss man doch die Gesetze entsprechend anpassen, damit nicht so viel dagegen äh verstoßen wird.
Immer wieder schön der Lokbuchnetzpolitik äh das Gesetz verstößt gegen die Geheimdienste. Das haben wir äh hier,
eben auch bei diesem ersten Reformpaket wo du mit Anna schon drüber gesprochen hast und wo äh viele Experten zu dem Fazit kommen, dass es eben bisher illegale Überwachungspraktiken des BND einfach,
legalisiert und äh teilweise sogar ausweitet. Ähm die zweite Hälfte des Reformpaketes beschäftigt sich damit.
Wie man denn die Geheimdienstkontrolle sicherstellen kann und ähm.
Ändert also, dass äh Artikel zehn Gesetz und das äh Kontrollgremiumsgesetz oder Kontrollgremium-Gesetz,
und zwar wie folgt. Es gibt ja immer die Klage des Kontrollgremiums, dass es ähm so,
überlastet ist und kaum Möglichkeit hat dieser Tätigkeit.
Gebührend nachzugehen und gleichzeitig eine sehr schlechte Kooperation von Seiten der Geheimdienstvertreter,
feststellen muss, sodass Christian Ströbel ja schon mehrmals betont hat von den richtigen Krachern,
erfährt der dann auch aus den Zeitungen weil ja häufig die,
Vertreter der Geheimdienste der Bundesregierung dann eben äh am nachher sagen, ah ja Mist. Dafür hatten wir, als wir uns da getroffen haben, keine Zeit mehr, weil ich ihnen ja so lange erzählt habe, äh wie gefährlich die Vierzehnjährigen,
Terroristen sind. Und mit diesem Gesetz soll es jetzt einen ständigen Bevollmächtigten des Kontrollgremiums geben,
Der die monatlichen Sitzungen vorbereitet und
Sachverhalte prüft. Soll jemand sein, der die Befähigung zum Richteramt oder zum Hören, nichttechnischen Verwaltungsdienst hat und von diesem Gremium für,
fünf Jahre ernannt werden. Das klingt erstmal ganz schön.
Aber es ist noch relativ unklar, welche Kompetenzen denn jetzt wieder dieser Bevollmächtigte hat, ist das ein ein besserer,
Sekretär oder eine bessere Sekretärin, die ähm Termine vereinbart und äh Einladungen verschickt, ja? Oder ist das eine Person, die quasi,
Mit der gleichen Berechtigung wie das Kontrollgremium selber äh da zukünftig mit einer Vollzeitstelle ähm über die Flure marschiert.
Ja und vor allem wenn das sich dann sozusagen aus dem juristischen Bereich äh bezieht, ähm also irrekrutiert
Sprich, ne, Richteramt et cetera, heißt mal wieder die Jura Abteilung, ne? Äh dann ist das sozusagen nicht das, was das PKG derzeit im Wesentlichen ist, nämlich Abgeordnete.
Ähm also es gibt die ähm also die Opposition sagt, wir wünschen, also sie sind ja trotzdem frei in der Bestimmung, ne? Also sie lominieren ja diese Person. Hm.
Na gut. Nach den entsprechenden Mehrheitsverhältnissen.
Weil die Opposition sagt also ne, wir hätten eigentlich gerne äh mehr äh personelle Ressourcen,
und würden gerne die Rolle der Abgeordneten und ihrer Mitarbeiter stärken, also das, was du auch sagst, sie möchten weniger Häuptlinge und mehr Indianer,
anstelle einer weiteren Ebene die Informationen filtert, also Kleine, wie ist dann mit diesen Bevollmächtigten umzugehen? Ähm.
Also das ist eine Sache. Kriegt kriegen jetzt eine Stelle abgestellt. Ähm was nicht drin ist, ist eine Stärkung der Kontrollrechte der,
Minderheit,
denn dieser ständige Bevollmächtigte soll auf Weisung des PKGR tätig werden. Also des ganzen Gremiums.
Und ähm da ist natürlich dann schon davon auszugehen, dass,
die äh Regierungsparteien, die wie in jedem anderen Ausschuss auch natürlich auch im parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium die Mehrheit haben. Damit,
Opposition überstimmen können und diesen diesen Mitarbeiter da entsprechend lenken können,
das wird natürlich äh scharf kritisiert, denn was du ja eigentlich möchtest, ist, dass die dass die Geheimdiensttätigkeiten natürlich möglichst von der von den Minderheiten äh,
wahrgenommen werden, weil diese natürlich ein Auge darauf lenken, wo tritt die Regierung,
In ihren Tätigkeiten hier über rote Linien, äh die man nutzen kann, um äh der Regierung,
zu schaden und wir haben da jetzt im und das ist ja durchaus erstmal die also das willst du ja, ne? Dass da eine eine Geheimdienstkontrolle stattfindet von Leuten, die bereit sind äh richtig schön,
Dreck aufzuwirbeln, das findet ja eben nicht statt und wird auch unter den,
momentan mehr als Verhältnissen von sieben äh viermal CDU, dreimal SPD, einmal Linke, einmal Grüne,
natürlich klar ist, warum dieses Gremium relativ still oder relativ schwach ist.
Also auch hier, genauso wie bei dem ersten Teil, im Prinzip eine Entmachtung der Kontrolle, ja? Man sagt immer so schön Reform, Reform, sind ja immer so schön Reformhaus. Ja.
Der findet keine Entmachtung statt, der findet nur keine.
Verstärkung der Macht, also da äh also Entmachtung äh ob von einem Zustand, von aus, von einem niedrigen Niveau äh werden dann noch weitere Abstriche eingeleitet.
Eine Maßnahme, die sinnvoll gewesen wäre und die sich hier ganz offenbar ganz offenkundig anbietet, äh wird eben nicht ergriffen.
Dann.
Wird das Problem angegangen, was hier gerade schon mal kurz eindeutete, dass sie eben da in diesem PKGR sitzen und äh ihnen die ganzen dicken Klopper in der Regel einfach gar nicht erzählt werden mit der Begründung, ja, hast ja gar nicht gefragt,
Hast ja nicht gefragt, ob wir das machen, also brauchte ich dir das ja auch nichts zu sagen. Witzig, Geheimdienst, ne? Du musst halt Fragen würfeln. Ähm deswegen.
Da könnte man doch mit einer AI dagegen vorgehen. Also.
Also es gibt eine, es gibt im jetzigen Gesetz äh für das PKGR, den Passus, dass man über Vorgänge, besondere Bedeutung umfassend unterrichten muss.
Ähm und es wurde auch schon äh gerügt, dass das eben andauernd nicht passiert,
der äh gibt eine Äußerung von BND Präsident
Geiger, äh dem ehemaligen BMW-Präsident Geiger, der eben sagte, ja, ja, die Zeit äh reicht eben leider nicht aus, die hat hier andere in dem Artikel auch nochmal schön zitiert. Darf deswegen soll in dem neuen Gesetz jetzt drei
Regelbeispiele für Vorgänge von besonderer Bedeutung definiert werden.
Über die das PKGR informiert werden muss.
Und diese äh Vorgänge sind definiert als erstens. Wesentliche Änderungen im Lagebild der inneren und äußeren Sicherheit.
Im Prinzip natürlich das, was sie ohnehin machen, darunter fällt ja im Prinzip einfach, wenn wenn irgendwo Grund für Terrorpanik ist, dann erzählt man das da, ja,
Behördeninterne Vorgänge mit erheblichen Auswirkungen auf die Aufgabenerfüllung.
Natürlich auch wieder so eine Definitionssache äh und.
Ausm Ruder gelaufene Weihnachtspartys zum Beispiel.
Und Einzelvorkommnisse, die Gegenstand politischer Diskussionen oder öffentlicher Berichterstattung sind. Ist ja auch witzig, ne? Also wenn es schon in der ähm.
Wenn es schon in der, in der Zeitung steht.
Kotiert wird, ja. Mhm.
Mal jetzt ernsthaft darüber reden? Ähm, das ist natürlich schön, immerhin hast du da mal eine Konkretisierung, die Frage ist, ist das jetzt 'ne abschließende Liste,
oder ist das eine ähm Bei.
Fehlung, ja. Mhm.
Gleichzeitig wird's auch direkt wieder eingeschränkt, denn weiterhin wird geschwiegen zu Informationen von ausländischen Behörden,
Das heißt genau die internationale Kooperation der Geheimdienste, die eigentlich ja unser Thema nun ist seit längerer Zeit und für die wir eine Untersuchungsausschuss haben und sagen, die wird genau von diesen
Berichtspflichten wieder ausgenommen. Ähm, Hans-Christian Ströbele hat da gegenüber,
Netzpolitik Org gesagt, dass parlamentarische Kontrolle bleibt also auch
künftig darauf angewiesen, erst aus den Medien von diesen wichtigen Vorgängen zu erfahren. Zum Beispiel verschwiegene Besuche deutscher Geheimdienste in Foltergefängnissen in Guantanamo oder Damaskus,
die Kooperationen zur Datenlieferung ähm an die USA oder NSA wie zum Beispiel Eikonal. Auch davon hätten wir mit dem neuen Gesetz nicht erfahren.
Und sonstige Geheimverträge mit ausländischen Dienst. Das heißt, auch da wieder genau hier an dem Punkt, wo es jetzt eigentlich gerade kracht, genau da äh schränken wir es auch wieder ein.
Weil es ja geheim.
Und jetzt gibt es ähm eine Debatte darüber.
Mit wem dürfen denn diese Abgeordneten im parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium überhaupt reden? Momentan mit niemandem.
Und.
Weil ist ja geheim.
Genau, also die gehen dahin, hören sich die aus allen, dürfen sie nach Hause gehen, ja?
Auch wirklich ein super Kont.
Eine Kontrolle äh das ist echt äh irre. Und ähm,
Jetzt gibt es in dem aktuellen Gesetzesentwurf den Vorschlag, dass die Abgeordneten zumindest ihre Fraktionsvorsitzenden in Kenntnis setzen dürfen. Wenn diese darum bitten,
Also du kannst nicht einfach sagen es kannst nicht einfach sagen, ey übrigens hier Fraktionsvorsitzender,
Du hast keine Ahnung, was ich da gestern gehört habe. Muss ich dir mal erzählen, sondern du musst quasi darauf warten, dass er dich darum bittet. Äh,
Und jetzt ist natürlich wieder die Frage, wo waren soll der Fraktionsvorwissende wissen, dass er dich wonach er dich fragen soll, ja?
Wird jetzt.
Im Sinne von konkret zu einem bestimmten Thema Fragen, so genauso wie man konkret die Geheimdienst.
Na ja, ich denke mal, da da schreibt man dann halt eine SMS und sagt, frag mich mal zu dem und dem Thema oder so, das kriegt man ja noch irgendwie hin, wenn man da von einer,
aber genau dieser äh Vorschlag ist gerade noch,
in der Diskussion und da weiß, also zwischen SPD und CDU und da weiß man noch nicht genau, ob dieser am Ende drin sein wird oder nicht.
Da hat man sich gesagt, na ja okay, ähm wisselblower Schutz braucht man ja schon so ein bisschen. Äh lass uns doch mal überlegen.
Ob Geheimdienst, Mitarbeiter,
Sich an das parlamentarische Kontrollgremium wenden dürfen. Das dürfen sie nach äh heutiger Regelung auch schon, aber sie müssen,
Gleichzeitig ihre Vorgesetzten informieren. Also du bist quasi sagst du, okay, hier ist echt die Kacke am Dampfen, das geht auf keine Kuhhaut. Ähm ich
äh lieke das jetzt nicht an Netzpolitik Org, aber,
Ich will zumindest mal den parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium Bescheid sagen, weil das geht nun mal echt nicht. Und ähm nach aktueller, nach aktueller Gesetzeslage kannst das machen,
Du musst aber deinem Vorgesetzten Bescheid sagen und sagst halt so, ey, übrigens hier.
Ich lege jetzt mal.
Ich ich gehe jetzt mal zu den äh zum zum Feind,
und äh und erzähl denen sowas, ja? Dann kannst du dir ungefähr vorstellen äh was was die.
Was, was die.
Was das Checkmark in der elektronisch gehaltenen Personalakte ist, ähm dass du bei den nächsten Beförderungen,
nicht mehr zur nicht mehr in Erwägung gezogen wirst und dass du natürlich auch zu entsprechenden Meetings nicht mehr eingeladen wirst,
Jetzt.
Kein Teilnahme.
Sollen sie, jetzt sollen sie zum PKGR gehen können ohne ihren Vorgesetzten den vor zu informieren,
aber sie müssen zu dem gesamten Gremium gehen und nicht zu einzelnen Abgeordneten.
Nicht, dass ihr jetzt alle zum Ströbel marschieren.
Nicht, dass sie alle zum Ströbele gehen und der dann auf einmal weiß, wo der Hase langläuft und die entsprechenden Fragen stellt.
Sie müssen auch die Regierungsspitze noch mit.
Und jetzt kommt und sie müssen auch die Regierungsspitze einladen und die Regierungsspitze acht an ihrer Zahl momentan. Sieben stimmt. Ähm dürfen dann.
Ihren Namen an die Geheimdienste weiterleiten.
Oh Gott. Also der See. Oh Man.
Oder so ein Burkhard Lischka oder so oder,
sagst du Freunde, also echt kaarige Sache, ich hab mein Vorgesetzten nichts gesagt und dann hast du halt eine eine Reihe von eben sagen wir mal sieben, also neun Personen von denen du bei sieben,
den zumindest den erhöhten Verdacht haben muss, dass die nicht den Mund halten werden, ne.
Mann, ey.
Das ist echt sehr schön, wie sie es wieder.
Ist das eine Bananenrepublik.
Gefreut hat man sich über öffentliche Anhörungen, also es wird jährliche öffentliche Anhörungen der deutschen Geheimdienstchefs vor dem äh PKGR geben.
Wir kennen das aus den USA, da gibt es das schon lange, hat also jetzt auch nichts Schlimmes, nix, nichts nennenswertes verhindern können, weil sie da ja einfach sich auch mitunter hinstellen und einfach lügen,
Ähm.
Öffentliche Anhörungen werden aber immerhin mal was Neues in ähm in Deutschland, denn bisher sind alle diese Sitzungen geheim. Es wird kein, noch nicht mal ein Wort Protokoll erstellt und ähm.
Da wäre also die Forderung der Opposition eben schon seit langem, dass man da mal wenigstens ein Tonwandmitschnitt äh anfertigt, damit man wenigstens nachher sagen kann, wer da überhaupt was gesagt hat,
Sie finden.
Das glaubst du, dass das passieren wird? Ich würde, wäre jetzt nicht überrascht, wenn sie das genauso handeln, wie jetzt bei dem NSA-Ausschuss, weil das ja alles super sensitiv ist, gibt's aber wieder kein offizielles Protokoll und da muss ich dann äh andere und andere da wieder hinsetzen und irgendwie alles wieder runter tippen.
Dann sind wenigstens ihre Arbeitsplätze für die äh Zukunft gesichert.
Einmal im Jahr, also.
Also da wird man auch nochmal sehen, was es da äh was es da gibt, aber es ist sehr schön, wie sie immer so noch so ein ganz kleines Ava einbringen. Und ähm,
Um das denn da wieder am Ende zu verbessern? Ich denke, dass äh das entscheidende Urteil ist natürlich hier, dass von äh Ströbele, der eben langjährige Erfahrung in diesem Gremium hat und er sagt,
gegenüber Netzpolitik Org. Der Gesetzesentwurf enttäuscht. Er beseitigt die Defizite der Kontrolle der Geheimdienste nicht,
Oppositionsrechte gegen die Regierungsmehrheit werden nicht gestärkt, es bleibt weiterhin unbestimmt, was jetzt Vorgänge von besonderer Bedeutung sind, über die den PKGR zu berichten ist
Besuche deutscher Geheimdienste in Foltergefängnissen, äh Kooperation zur Datenlieferung an die USA
und Geheimverträge äh mit ausländischen Diensten müssen auch in Zukunft nicht berichtet werden, das heißt sie werden wir weiterhin aus der Presse erfahren, was ja immer das Leid ist, dass alle das Leid war
Ströbele geklagt hat.
Der ständige Bevollmächtigte, so seine Worte, soll die Tätigkeit des Parlaments zwar nicht ersetzen, sondern unterstützen, aber eben auch nur auf Antrag und im Interesse der Mehrheit,
Whisle Blower aus den Diensten dürfen nicht einzelne Abgeordnete ansprechen, sondern müssen in das PKGRG ihre Eingaben machen und gehen,
gleich und diese gehen gleich auch an die Bundesregierung. Vor allem fehlt jede Sanktionsmöglichkeit des PKGR, wenn wie Geschehen nicht oder falsch berichtet wird.
Und es wird keine Aufzeichnung der Sitzung auf Tonträger geben, sodass äh die spätere Feststellung des Gesagten unmöglich bleibt. Also,
man sieht, hier gibt es nicht wirklich die Lösung eines äh Problemes äh dessen man öffentlich,
sich gewahr ist.
Also es ist wirklich zum Schämen. Ja. Das ist wirklich zum Schämen. Also es es ist so absurd.
Vor allem ist einfach so viel von dem Zeug drin, was wir die ganze Zeit jetzt in den letzten ein, zwei Jahren UK, USA vorgeworfen haben, dass das so ihre Grundhaltung ist.
Und das ähm das soll jetzt alles noch vor der Sommerpause durchgehauen werden oder was.
Ähm ich das weiß ich nicht genau, wie da der die Zeitlinie gerade ist. Ähm aber vermutlich flott,
Ich kann jetzt mal ganz kurz schauen, deshalb also das ist jetzt der Gesetzesentwurf. Man,
Schau mal ganz kurz. Der ist ja auch äh also er ist ja noch nicht final abgestimmt und es handelt sich hier wieder um ein quasi ein League, ja, den das äh Zwetick-Org hier an dieser Stelle.
Ne, also.
Hat, das ist also der ist also aus den,
Verhandlungen rausgefallen. Es gibt eben mehrere noch strittige Punkte. Insbesondere eben der äh dieser ständige Bevollmächtigte, wieder genau ähm
ausgestattet ist ähm.
Da gibt's also eine Reihe an roten Markierungen, die andere hier nochmal vorgenommen hat, wo gesagt wird, da gibt's eben äh auch noch Unklarheit, aber man sieht jetzt schon, wenn das der Aufschlag ist, äh dann weißt du, wohin der Hase läuft, ne.
Nochmal gut, dass die Öffentlichkeit nicht von irgendeinem Groß äh Weltereignis abgelehnt ist.
Eben. Deswegen machen wir hier auch nicht Logbuch EM. Ähm es gibt aber noch mehr noch weitere schöne äh Sachen.
Oh, sind doch schon alle liegen doch jetzt schon alle irgendwie.
Wir kommen so ein bisschen.
Palmiert äh.
Wir kommen so ein bisschen zu den äh wir kommen so ein bisschen zu den Kurzmeldungen. Also im Moment finden.
Mehrere gerichtliche Auseinandersetzungen zu Etblockern statt, ja? Äh wir haben das auch immer wieder erwähnt,
dass es dann eben mal AdBlocker sollen dann komplett verboten werden, dann geht es darum ob ob AdBlocker, Blogger, Blogger äh oder AdBlocker, Blogger Erkenner ähm oder außer Kraftsetzer verboten werden sollen. Da gibt's jetzt,
die gerade stattfindenden Verfahren ähm,
wo auch dieser Youtuber ähm eine Rolle spielt, der da verklagt wurde, weil er auf YouTube mal eben erklärt hat, wie man äh.
Blockaden.
AdBlocker, die Ad-Blockersperre bei Bild umgeht, da gab's ja dann auch schon diese diese ersten Urteile, wo man irgendwie davon ausgegangen ist, dass das die Umgehung eines Kumpierschutzes ist oder net nicht Urteil, aber diese Argumentation,
da da ist also gerade Musik drin und wir beobachten das jetzt mal mit Interesse. Und jetzt gab's einen sehr spannenden Artikel ähm.
Von äh Friedhelm Geis auf äh Golem, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, wo er sagt, es ihm ist da so der Bericht der Bund, Länderkommission zur Medienkonvergenz aufgefallen,
der schon etwas,
da ist und irgendwie öffentlich rumliegt und da steht ein interessanter Satz drin und der lautet ergänzend wurde die Kommission in der Besprechung der Bundeskanzlerin mit den Regierungschefinnen und Regierungschefs der Länder.
Zum ersten Zwischenbericht der Bundländerkommission zur Medienkonferenz am dritten Dezember zweitausendfünfzehn darum gebeten auch die Themen,
Media Agenturen und at Blogger zu behandeln. Das bestehen,
gesetzgeberischen Handlungsbedarf bei Media Agenturen soll weiter geprüft werden
Bezüglich der Thematik AdBlocker soll eine zeitnahe Prüfung durch Bund und Länder klären. Jetzt kommt der interessante Punkt
ob im Hinblick auf die wirtschaftlichen Auswirkungen und damit verbundenen medienpolitischen Risiken,
Gegebenenfalls eine gesetzliche Flankierung geboten ist.
Und die Kommission schließt sich dieser Kritik an und sagt, sie sieht,
Das Geschäftsmodell von Edblockern als rechtlich und mit Blick auf die Refinanzierung journalistisch, redaktionelle Angebote, auch medienpolitisch als,
problematisch an und hält die Prüfung gesetzlicher Regelungen für erforderlich. Das heißt.
Die wollen jetzt die AdBlocker verbieten.
Ja, viel Spaß.
Oder ihnen irgendwelche Regulationen aufs Auge drücken, die äh sicherstellen. Äh dass äh die Geschäftsmodelle äh entsprechen entsprechend weiter funktionieren.
Und ich frage mich mal, wie denn also das wird echt spannend, wenn man jetzt sagt, ja hier, also dann machen sie halt irgendwie eine bestimmte,
bestimmte Firmen müssen dann eben nach Panama ziehen oder was? Wollen wir dann jetzt demnächst äh die die Browser die Browser Plugins äh nicht mehr runterladen dürfen,
wird Apple die AdBlocker Dinger in Deutschland nicht mehr verkaufen äh oder im App Store anbieten dürfen,
Also was soll das denn jetzt, ja, oder eben eine Regulation, ne? Dann werden die halt zu Reparationszahlungen verpflichtet oder so, ne?
Also das ist äh oder man äh ne verbietet eben AdBlocker äh äh Bloggererkenner oder sowas, ne? Also da wird auch wieder da wurde echt wieder denkst so habt ihr eigentlich irgendwie den Knall auch gehört so? Ähm.
Ja, na ja gut, ich meine, dem kann man ja begegnen, dann heißt es halt äh künftig nicht mehr äh Edblocker, sondern Virenschutz.
Ja äh.
Dann sollen sie mal wieder einen Schutz verbieten.
Ja, dann kommt noch die Gilde der der Virenschreiber und sagt, dass ihr ihr Geschäftsmodell jetzt bedroht wird. Also.
Allein das. Ja.
Da wäre ich jetzt also, ne, allein, dass sie darüber nachdenken, zeigt dir schon wieder und von diesen Bundländer Dingern. Man denke nur immer wieder an das Jugendmedien,
Schutzdienstvertrag und.
Äh Leistungsschutzrecht kam mir die ganze Zeit ermüdet. Wieder von hinten durch den Kopf.
Jugendmedienschutz, Staatsvertrag und was nicht alles. Na ja.
Echte Experten.
Ja die Experten werden sich der Sache jetzt annehmen und sehen Bedarf an gesetzlichen Regelungen, beziehungsweise eine Prüfung.
Ja, oh Bayer. Aber immerhin ist ja die störerhaftung jetzt weg.
Und genau, da gab's dann irgendwie das war da habe ich auch irgendwie äh nicht ganz verstanden, wie das war, äh so wie das zustande kam. Im Bundesrat gab es nämlich dann durchaus äh Kritik an der
vor ungefähr einem Monat beschlossenen Änderungen des Telemediengesetzes, also wir reden hier um die Frage der Störerhaftung, wo wir ja jetzt auch ausführlich schon dargestellt haben,
Dass einerseits gesagt wird, ja, hier ähm Störerhaftung ist damit abgeschafft, andererseits gesagt wird, ist sie nicht. Der Bundes ähm.
Rath hat ein Erst äh moniert, dass äh es hier Rechtsunsicherheiten weiterhin gibt und dass man anregt, nochmal äh sich da mal irgendwie,
das regelmäßig zu bewerten, ob die Ziele auch tatsächlich erreicht werden ähm und irgendwie kurz darauf war dann die Meldung äh der Bundesrat stimmt per Reform äh der Störerhaftung zu, die,
der Antrag, die rechtsuntersicherheiten zu klären wurde, abgelehnt.
Und die Lücken bleiben bestehen. Es kommt also jetzt auf die Interpretation durch die Gerichte an, was wir übrigens glaube ich gar nicht so äh ausgeführt hatten, ist das ja der äh,
Dass ja von der Abmahnkanzlei Walldorf Rommer schon gesagt wurde, äh ist in Ordnung, macht euch mal keine Sorgen um uns,
Wir machen weiter. Äh Brigitte Zypries hat aber jetzt gesagt, sie verspricht ein Ende der Abmahnungen, WLAN-Betreiber sind genau wie Excess Provider von der Haftung ausgeschlossen, ganz gleich auf die privat oder gewerblich sein,
Äh nun ist sie aber halt die ehemalige Bundesjustizministerin, insofern äh werden wir sehen,
Was da passieren soll. Das Gesetz soll aber zweitausendachtzehn dann einer Evaluierung unterzogen werden und dann wird äh geguckt,
ob das Gesetz seine Ziele erreicht hat. Einfacher Check wäre natürlich zu sehen, gibt es zweitausendachtzehn noch die Abmahnindustrie, wenn ja, dann hat das Gesetz sein Ziel,
nicht erreicht.
Und wenn nein, dann hat es sein Ziel erreicht. Wir werden da also interessiert sehen nach welchem skurrilen Maßstäben dieses Gesetz zwanzig achtzehn bewertet wird.
Ja, das äh dieses dieser störerhafte Reform ist, es ist so ein bisschen die digitale äh Mietpreisbremse mit äh äh entsprechender Durchschlagskraft. Das wird irgendwie auch nicht greifen.
Verstehe das auch nicht, warum da einfach der Wille nicht da ist. Ich meine, wer macht sich denn bitte damit gemein mit dieser Massenabmahnungsgeschichte? Die FDP ist auch gar nicht mehr in der äh Bundesregierung, also.
Na ja, aber demnächst haben wir sowieso ganz andere Sorgen mit unserem Internet, denn die NATO hat den Cyberrome jetzt offiziell zum Kriegsschauplatz ernannt.
Aber ich habe beruhigt. Ja. Heißt was?
Na sie macht die NATO macht im Prinzip genau das Gleiche, äh wie die Bundeswehr ja jetzt auch, dass sie sagt, okay, es gibt eben äh den die klassischen Einsatzgebiete Luft, See und Land und Netzoperationen ähm gehören,
dazu. Was.
Jetzt her, Marine, Luft und Cyber. Ja. So sieht die vier militärischen Elemente.
Ja
So super.
Und der ähm da geht sie jetzt also da gibt's natürlich jetzt interessante,
äh Punkt, weil das natürlich auch weil sie sagen, okay, Cyberangriffe abzuwehren, wird jetzt also Teil der gemeinsamen Verteidigungslinie.
Ähm,
Und die NATO sieht sich da also jetzt im Rahmen eines Hybriden militärischen Konflikts und deswegen müsse eben der Fokus der Allianz erweitert werden. Und jetzt bin ich mal äh,
gespannt, wie äh die NATO denn in Zukunft da den Cyber-Bündnisfall,
sieht, ja? Und man wird also,
interessiert beobachten können, ob sie dann demnächst sagen, okay, hier wir wurden von denen gecybert.
Oder ein ein Mitgliedsland wurde gesagt, jetzt müssen wir da müssen wir jetzt gegenzabern.
Mitgliedsland der NATO wurde gecybert. Ähm ja.
Müssen alle mit zabern.
Denn.
Heute wird zurückgesalbert.
Die NATO-Partner hatten sich zweitausendvierzehn nach langem hin und her darauf versteinigt, verständigt,
dass ein Cyberangriff einen Kriegsakt darstellen und die Schutzbestimmung nach Artikel fünf des Bündnis
lösen kann, wonach die Allianz Gemeinschaft nicht einem Attackierenden, einem einem attackierten Mitgliedshilfe kommen kann. Ich glaube, einem attackierenden auch, aber das ist eben äh das ist ja dann eher Zwischenindsam.
Ja, ist ja auch nicht so einfach, dann irgendwie so die Stoßrichtung so ohne weiteres festzustellen, ne, wenn jetzt beide sozusagen da aus ihrem eigenen äh äh Land äh äh in die anderen IP-Netze äh reinstrahlen, ja? Äh das hat die Frage, wer hat jetzt eigentlich wen angegriffen,
auch offen. Die Saba Nase rum und dann.
Die NATOs heibert schon seit längerem, ne? Also sie haben ja irgendwie so einen Cyberware-Handbuch mal irgendwie rausgegeben.
Jo, aber ich meine, was bedeutet das hier sozusagen für den Bündnisfall, ja? Also, wenn jetzt äh da Polen angesabert wird, äh muss dann da zurückgesabert werden.
Seit zweitausendvierzehn hatten sie das schon gesagt, dass ein äh Cyberangriff ein kriegsakt darstellen könnte und wonach dann eben auch gemeinschaftlich zu helfen ist. Und das haben sie jetzt auch nochmal in einer äh klar, in einer,
Also jetzt haben sie auch gesagt, okay, das ist so. Cyber ist jetzt auch Operationsfeld. Das wirst du jetzt überall sehen.
Und ähm das ist natürlich auch wieder äh traurig.
Aber trägt eben wahrscheinlich auch einer gewissen äh Entwicklung Rechnung.
Schön wäre es natürlich hier äh sich eher an die Cyberpeace-Kampagne äh des,
des Forums, der Informatikerin für Frieden und gesellschaftliche Verantwortung äh zu wenden äh zu halten, die eben sagen, wir,
fordern, dass es keine offensiven Cyberstrategien gibt, dass man sich verpflichtet, keine Cyberwaffen zu entwickeln.
Und das Ganze eben nicht nur in Deutschland, sondern,
international, dass wir eben die andere Möglichkeit äh auf die auf den Cyberkag quasi zu reagieren, wie auf die,
Bedrohung,
die nukleare Bedrohung, die ausgeht von nuklearen Waffen, dass man also sagt, wir ächten diese Waffen, wir sorgen dafür, dass sie keine hat. Außer die acht äh Nationen, die oder neun
die sie ohnehin schon haben und gerade ganz froh sind.
Dieter Limshalber, Sicherheitsrat sich gegenseitig blockieren und irgendwie nicht an Griffspakte schließen und so. Oh, war ja. Das wird viel wenigstens einer vor zehn Jahren erzählt hätte. Wir hätten noch irgendwie laut gelacht, oder?
Fünfzehn, zwanzig, wo zwanzig haben wir darüber gelach.
Mit unserem sechsundfünfzig K Modell war klar, dass wir darüber lachen, ne, aber.
Aber ist jetzt ungefähr so zwanzig Jahre her, dass diese ganze Geschichte mit äh Rumscalbern und und eine Gefahr darstellen, ja eigentlich auch so ein Hackerthema geworden ist.
Yes, also das.
Was war denn, wann war denn dieser Atomversuche von Frankreich? Die letzten.
Das war wahrscheinlich irgendwann Ende Neunziger.
Zwanzig Jahre her sein, ne.
Atoll meinst du jetzt?
Genau und da gab's ja dann diese diese erste äh Geschichte,
griff ja dann ja sechsundneunzig muss das gewesen sein. Zwanzig Jahre her. Da gab's ja,
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, welche Gruppe das hat, aber da wurde ja dieser Begriff des Hacktivisum geboren. Der so eine,
Na ja, der so ein bisschen so ein so ein, auch finde ich so ein bisschen so ein Sündenfall,
der Hackerbewegung auch markiert, jetzt nicht unbedingt viel passiert, aber dieser Begriff wurde geboren und teilweise hat er sich ja auch noch bis heute gehalten, auch wenn er so ein bisschen anders interpretiert wird, ne? Also
Ich glaube, wenn man heute von Hacktivisum spricht, gibt's da so eine positive äh Assoziation damit,
so mehr so Hacker sind Aktivisten, aber das ist nicht das, was es meint, sondern tatsächlich war das ja im Prinzip die Ankündigung einer Detox-Attacke.
Die damals technisch in dem Sinne überhaupt, also weder weder technisch auch nur ansatzweise so durchgeführt werden konnte,
wie das da halt posidiert wurde. Es war mir so eine so eine Öffentlichkeitsgeschichte. Das ging irgendwie von Mexiko aus und äh,
wo aber quasi eben,
Ich nenn sie mal unlautere Mitte ins Feld geführt worden und das war so ein bisschen diese Geburtsstunde, dieses dieses Begriffs der bis heute halt ein bisschen unscharf geblieben ist,
Und das war so ein bisschen die erste ähm,
öffentliche Diskussionen, die ich so mitbekommen habe, wo im Prinzip solche ähm Cyber-Reihen äh eine Rolle gespielt haben. Und jetzt haben wir das sozusagen schon auf NATO-Level.
Eskaliert.
Ich habe jetzt gerade mal,
war mir das nicht so bekannt war äh gegoogelt und einen interessanten Artikel von Julian Assange vom fünfundzwanzigsten November zweitausendsechs gefunden, wo er sagt, der,
die die Geburtsstände des Hectovismbäre neunzehnhundertneunundachtzig als das US,
die US-Department of Energy und die NASA äh von einem antinuklearen Wankwarm befallen waren. Das war also ein,
ein Computerwurm, der ähm spezifisch diese Leute angegriffen hat,
und äh war der sogar der zweite nach dem äh berühmten Moritzwurm, dem ersten.
Der Moritz wollen wir ja nun überhaupt kein geplanter Angriff, sondern ich war ja eher so ein so ein Unfall, also immer jetzt der zweite Wurm, ja. Ja gut, weiß nicht, ob da irgendjemand diesen Begriff auch schon äh verwendet hat, das ist mir jetzt neu.
Das ja, das ja, ist auch egal. Ich fand's nur interessant. Wollte auch was Kluges sagen.
Auch so 'ne Interpretation ja die ist schon in Ordnung, du hast ja jetzt schon genug kluges gesagt, ich dachte ich sag mal nochmal was Kluges dazu. Und jetzt haben wir es glaube ich.
Weißt du auch, wie viele Atombomben auf dem Moro Road toll gezündet wurden.
So insgesamt, wo viele.
Hundertachtundachtzig.
Natürlich. Dreistellig? Schlimm.
Hundertsiebenundvierzig unterhalbierdisch, einundvierzig,
evaliert ist, wenn man sich da Bilder anguckt, die haben echt einen schönen Strand da und ich gehe davon aus, dass man da im Moment noch relativ geringe Grundstückspreise hat,
Allerdings natürlich auch wegen der nuklearen Versorgung eher ein langfristiges Investment,
bis man auf diesen Fleckenerde nochmal Frieden findet.
Oh Gott, was für eine schlimme Zeit, ey.
Ja. Ihr dürft dann auch mit zeibern,
Schon mal Eingangs äh nochmal erwähnt. Wir freuen uns sehr über Kommentare. Wir äh möchten gerne richtig gestellt werden. Wir möchten gerne äh
kluge Anschlussgedanken lesen und das sollt ihr gerne tun, so ist sich denn konkret auch auf Sendungen bezieht in,
Sendungskommentaren auf Log Brunnenspolitik DE. Wer darüber hinaus Lust hat mit
Gleichgesinnten, Hörerinnen und Hörern ins Gespräch zu kommen, da empfiehlt sich die Mitterebene Community das Textsystem, wo es auch Einloggenheitspolitik
Kanal gibt, dort kann man auch gerne weiter diskutieren, Nachfragen stellen et cetera. Wir garantieren jetzt hier keine
unmittelbare Support-Responts in vierundzwanzig Stunden von unserer Seite aber das wäre auf jeden Fall ein Ort wo ihr euch auch mal,
mit anderen Hörerinnen und Hörern vernetzen könnt, so es keine anderen Kanäle gibt, die ihr sofort al,
nennenswert erachtet.
So, damit sind wir am Ende für die dieswöchige Depression.
So sieht's aus. Also munter bleiben, Kopf hoch und wir sprechen uns nächste Woche wieder.
Tschüss.